alan québec cette année là j'étais loin
de me douter que ça allait changer ma
vie c'est la première fois que l'univers
du bédéiste michel rabagliati prend vie
au cinéma et c'est françois létourneau
qui prend les traits de paul un
personnage attachant que l'on voit
évoluer dans les livres depuis plus de
15 ans au canada d'une charte pour
s'apprécier mais je pense à vous donner
envie aux gens de découvrir paul à
québec nous si léopold sont d'excellents
jeunes à québec le film est tiré du
sixième album de la série
il raconte l'histoire de la famille
beaulieu un clan tissée serrée dont le
patriarche est gravement malade
incarnant des soeurs julie le breton
brigitte lafleur et myriam leblanc
traduisent le quotidien d'une famille
accompagnant un parent en fin de vie
juste un film parle de la mort mais sa
femme qui parle du legs de la
transmission donne de l'importance au
sida y viennent par fori pour vous
contre 1,207 bientôt hivernal pour que
dit que tu vu de l'impressionnante
distribution comprend aussi patrice
robitaille mathieu quesnel et louise
portal gilbert sicotte lui ces courtes
avec force et élégance le rôle du père
mourant sans jamais tomber dans le
misérabilisme un film poétique et
lumineux à l'image de l'oeuvre de michel
rabagliati dans le livre d'ailleurs on
l'a on est revenus des pages entières
des fois on me dit bon en transe page là
c'est bon on la tourne c'est vraiment
charmant voit que ce qui est sur écran
faire réagir
des centaines de personnes dans une
salle c'est quand même assez émouvant le
film prend tout de même des libertés
pour faire face aux défis que présente
et l'adaptation
j'ai tout fait confiance à respecter
l'esprit de la bande et des shows une
amende et ce ne sont pas dans le hall
d'accueil jean pronovost levé ce n'est
pas ce matin monsieur sans être
larmoyant paul à québec est un film
émouvant sur la fragilité de la vie
traitant de sujets graves avec légèreté
ici tanya lapointe radio canada montréal